hi how're you doing this one of those
videos I didn't plan on making this
video I just kind of assumed I was like
all right well we all know the situation
so I assumed everyone would know what I
would do and then I remember don't
assume it makes an ass out of you and me
that's what my mom always told me anyway
also communication is very important
also my videos tend to be light-hearted
so when I'm talking about the
coronavirus I'm not making light of it
I'm just I'm just saying so there's the
corona virus the corona virus is now a
pandemic and so we're in a corona virus
pandemic so hope y'all taking
precautions you know being safe washing
your hands being informs that's an
important one among this world of
internet misinformation yeah do that
look into thing but the reason I'm
making this video is because well in
terms of my channel how does this boil
down to my channel how does this affect
my channel because movie screenings
cancelled all of them like all until
further notice until question mark movie
release it's also postponed to like a
quiet place to was gonna be this week No
Mulan again no and that's just in March
but there are movies that are postponed
in May so it's not like I don't think
this is gonna be a thing where it's like
oh that thing happened in March April's
here it's fine but in the world where I
mostly do videos on new movie releases
and there are no new movie releases
planned and scheduled what does that
mean well really I don't plan on my
channel drastically changing other than
the fact that I won't be talking about
new movie releases obviously I will
still work to give you videos at the
same interval in the same quantity per
week that I usually would I mean if you
lined up things I have done videos on in
the history of my channel and things I
have not there's a lot more that I
haven't done videos on than I have so it
leaves a lot of entertainment that I can
talk about if I want to pull from the
past yeah I can do videos on movies that
have come out that I haven't seen TV
shows that I like that I just haven't
done a video on it's like alright well
now I'll do a video on it streaming
service movie streaming service shows
are we going to get a review of the
greatest bad movie of all time I don't
know I'd wanna make promises but I
suppose snack would be the time movie
trailers are tricky I mean usually you
know if a movie trailer comes out and I
want to talk about it I'll talk about
the movie trailer bus moment of movies
means probably postponement of movie
trailers so I'm not counting on movie
trailers movie news also tricky because
I feel like a lot of the movie news is
going to be coronavirus there's more of
the coronavirus
and how it's affected movies and why
this movies delayed more coronavirus and
so it's just I don't want to turn my
channel into a coronavirus channel in
fact I don't want to talk about the
coronavirus at all after this I mean
obviously I have to talk about it here I
have to touch on it here for the sake of
you know informing you and touching base
with you but after this I just don't
want to talk about it because I believe
firmly and I've always believed this
there's a need for escapism that people
are inundated with something that
stressing them out out there in the
world when they come to my channel I
don't want to stress them out with that
same thing people come here to escape
hear about a movie here's some jokes
maybe laugh have a good time that's what
I want to give people so when that the
whole thing is with my videos you know
let's still have fun video games also I
mean doom eternals coming out it's gonna
do one on doom eternal anyways one of
the games I'm really looking forward to
this year they're getting a video on
that Final Fantasy 7 remake scumming out
in April getting a video on that again
was gonna do it anyway because Final
Fantasy 7 didn't the demo would be weird
to do it on the demo not the game when
it comes out and if I get the urge to
play another game as well as the urge to
do a video on that game I'll do a video
on that I just actually finished playing
a game that I probably wouldn't have
done a video on but I want to do a video
on it this week in fact I feel like not
doing a video on this game would be
blasphemous you know I want to talk
about it so that's it no world bro movie
screenings cancelled new movie releases
delayed this is really my direct line of
communication with you so here you I
just wanted to touch base with you as
always thank you for watching my channel
subscribing to my channel I won't get
that bump like when people know there's
a new movie coming out weekly and they
know the new movie coming out that week
I feel like they look forward to it more
so that there's more eyes looking for a
review for it so I suspect the views
will probably dip a little bit so if you
want to I usually don't say this but if
you want to click that Bell for
notifications keep an eye out for my
channel every couple days check in on
what I may or may not have been
uploading that YouTube may or may not
have told you about that would help me
out I appreciate it I appreciate your
support and again be cautious be safe
wash your hands use precautions and most
of all be informed just inform yourself
look into a lot of what you hear out
there on social media because
misinformation it it's what's gonna
happen in situations like this
appreciate and love you all and as
always if you like what you've seen here
wanna see more click right here to see
more
[Music]